attention est-ce que tu connais le
portrait chinois dans l'habitation
or par exemple je te dise il était une
fleur la quelle fleur tu serais
absolument à nous ici on fait un truc un
peu plus pervers sembl ait des méthodes
actuelles c'est l'anti portrait chinois
si c'était une injure
vanessa paradis
ça va comment répondre et était un
accident cardiaque
c'était un insecte toi qui adore les
bêtes bogies c'est un microbe un microbe
[ __ ] je te dis pas vraiment et non des
micros quel genre de microbes
jean-louis un microbe ce2 ont mis le feu
à l'huile si tu étais un microbe une ali
ben ouais pourquoi pour parce que ça
résiste bien et dans les temps dans les
mauvais moments ça se renferme hainard
vie vingt ans après ça recommence à te
faire chier c'est le cas de le dire ça
c'est pas mal à toi si tu étais un
dictateur répond pas michel blanc
cinoche
en deux mots
pinochet un dictateur on perd alors le
psychanalyste bon je vais m'allonger
c'est dire en ville c'était une panne ou
panne
voilà la petite était une arme c'est sûr
tu vas répondre quoi tu connection les
couteaux c'est ce que ça signifie un nom
mon père me l'a dit une fois mais je
crois que ça mais depuis un an je sais
un couteau pour un psychanalyste je ne
sais pas pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est
un couteau
non mais t'as des nerfs de t'avoir belge
pas été dit que c'était une symbolique
du sexe de l'homme voilà tu y crois ça
n'en prend pas cela elle propose avec de
l'homme s'est taillé à toi si c'était un
chômeur je serai bien emmerdé oui ça a
été chaud moeurs quoi oui ça toucher les
assedic henry le chemin j'ai été
malheureux
ouais enfin moi je peux passer un
médecin pourquoi un bail non alors la
tête mais chez pas combien de temps je
souhaite m'inscrire important parce
qu'il m'en donnait à moins qu'apple a
évidemment un et ça ne gêne pas de
prendre je sais pas de sens bris pour
faire je te bute soirée et après toucher
les assedic pendant un an
non franchement cette étape qui me gêne
c'est de donner 60 % aux impôts sur les
200 briques ensuite puis sur les 40 %
qui restent devenait beaucoup pour les
assedic ensuite lorsque me reversent les
assedic d'ordonner 60% aux impôts ouais
ça ça me gêne beaucoup
donc je regrette pas non pas du tout
mais quand je donne 60 % impôts je ne
pense pas je ne demande pas qu'on me
traite de cinq jeux j'espère vous quand
je touche quoi j'ai droit
on peut me [ __ ] la paix par le traité
de [ __ ] d'accord ou alors sinon retour
nous promettre à plein temps ça va bien
si tu étais un professeur de danse de
danse c'est qu'il a fait aux yeux de
prof de piano c'est qu'ils jouent très
bien du bien-manger à peu près pas prof
pas prête un foyer de concertiste enfin
j'ai failli j'ai pas été mon service oui
moi ça j'ai failli être gagnant de la
république aussi ont failli tout est
prêt même ce que je fais j'ai fait ça a
failli faire du trapèze c'est ça hein
et c'est pourquoi je vais te laisser
tomber non vous avez pas peur c'est plus
compliqué de faire ce que tu fais
aujourd'hui avant je n'ai pas peur je me
suis inventé
ah bon ouais un jour sur la moquette de
coco rocha de coco et je me suis il
raflait tout la non mais je vais faire
du trapèze et puis je me suis présenté à
l'école du cirque quand j'avais 8 ans on
m'a dit qu'il fallait attendre d'avoir
dix ans alors entre les deux j'étais
impatient de changer d'avis t'aurais pas
aimé être éleveur d'escargots
j'adore les bêtes qu'on la sent que tu
es canada lui et ça sent la transition
actuelle 106 voix l'enchaînement comme
joram pour l'histoire de définir les
collègues à bon tu sais que ça peut
s'apprendre par correspondance être
éleveur d'escargots avec débit et bien
tu regardes